trade and investment at the U.S Africa
business Forum CEOs and private sector
leadership from over 300 American and
African companies will convene with the
heads of Delegation to catalyze
investment in critical sectors including
Health infrastructure energy
agribusiness and digital
the president will close the business
Forum on Wednesday with public remarks
later in the day he will host a small
group of leaders at the White House for
a discussion on upcoming presidential
elections in 2023 in Africa and U.S
support for free fair and credible polls
across the continent he will then host
Wednesday evening all 50 heads of
Delegation and their spouses for a
dinner here at the White House
Thursday is dedicated to high-level
discussions among Leaders with President
Biden opening the day with a session on
partnering on agenda 2063 the African
Union's strategic vision for the
continent a working lunch by vice
president Harris Will Follow That
session and then the president will
close the day with a discussion on food
security and Food Systems resilience
which as you all know is a critical
issue for our African Partners who have
been disproportionately impacted by the
rise in food and fertilizer prices and
disruptions to Global Supply chains as a
result of Russia's war against Ukraine
throughout the next three days and then
beyond the next three days we look
forward to leveraging the best of
America a truly unrivaled set of tools
across our government our private sector
and Civil Society to partner with and
support African institutions African
citizens and African nations to advance
our shared goals
the summit just to take a step back is
rooted in the recognition that Africa is
a key geopolitical player the continent
will shape the future not just of the
African people but also the world
President Biden believes that U.S
collaboration with African leaders as
well as with civil society and Business
Leaders and the diaspora women youth is
essential to unlocking the potential of
this decisive decade
as you know the president intends to
announce U.S support for the African
Union to join the G20 as a permanent
member it's past time for Africa to have
permanent seats at the table in
international organizations and
initiatives and the President also plans
to underscore his commitment to U.N
security Council reform including
support for a permanent member from the
African continent
working closely with Congress the U.S
will commit 55 billion dollars to Africa
over the course of the next three years
across a wide range of sectors to tackle
the core challenges of our time these
commitments build on the United States's
long-standing leadership and partnership
in develop development economic growth
health and Security in Africa over the
past three decades
you'll be hearing a number of
announcements over the coming days
specific deliverables in a number of
different areas new projects and
initiatives new funding streams but our
commitment to Africa extends well beyond
all of that too it's reflected in our
Decades of meaningful engagement
people-to-people ties and high quality
investments in our shared future and
really the spirit of this Summit is not
what we will do for African nations and
peoples but what we will do with African
nations and peoples and I will say one
other thing in in the Intensive
consultations we've had with African
leaders and African civil society and
other voices in the run-up to this
Summit a key question has been followed
through okay you're going to have the
summit what's going to happen once the
summit concludes to that end we will
have a new special representative for
U.S Africa leader Summit implementation
the state department plans to appoint
Ambassador Johnny person for this role
Ambassador Carson is very well known to
people across the continent of Africa he
brings a wealth of experience to the
position having dedicated his 37-year
career to diplomacy in Africa and we are
looking forward to working with him to
ensure that the announcements that get
get made over the next three days are
translated into durable actions that
last well beyond the summit
a last point and thank you for your
patience as we take as we approach the
new year I just want to take a moment to
reflect on the depth and breadth of
President Biden's foreign engagements
over 2022 from the Quad Summit in Tokyo
to the historic NATO Summit in Madrid to
consequential G7 and G20 Summits at
critical geopolitical moments to hosting
in separate Summits the leaders of the
Americas the Pacific Islands asean and
now of course the leaders of Africa this
year has marked one of the most high
paced substantive periods of
presidential engagement in foreign
policy in recent history and it's a
profound demonstration of the
president's approach to the world and a
powerful expression of the ways in which
a broad and diverse community of nations
are working together to uh to solve our
shared challenges with that I'd be happy
to take your questions April okay
um a couple of questions the same topics
trade Health Food security and National
security have been the topics of
presidents from Bill Clinton to George W
bush Barack Obama and now why are these
same issues still on the table after all
of these years and what has been the art
of success if you can measure it from
the Clinton years when Africa was put on
the table and then George W bush would
be considered the president who did the
most for Africa and then also if you can
talk about the lack that happened during
the last four years not focusing in on
Africa are you behind uh in some areas I
want to Africa well first the topics you
mentioned are the essential building
blocks of healthy societies healthy
economies healthy countries the world
over not just in Africa but everywhere
health
economics climate
peace and security these are not topics
that get resolved in four years or 40
years they are the topics upon which
durable Partnerships get built that a
government-to-government level business
to business and people to people so it
should come as no surprise that the
things that matter most to the people in
communities across the continent and
frankly to people in communities Across
America are going to be the top agenda
items for the summit and in each of
these areas we feel that we do have a
very strong record to stand on as the
United States dealing with Africa
whether it's in health and the
remarkable advances we've made against
HIV AIDS tuberculosis and malaria or as
President Biden will talk about the
support that we flowed to Africa during
the covid-19 pandemic and the work we
are now doing to help Africa stand up
its own capacity to manufacture vaccines
and Therapeutics going forward I could
walk through each of the other areas
economics and trade investment climate
tackling the climate crisis the
president was just at an African cop in
charmel Sheikh Egypt where he laid out a
series of initiatives relating to
adaptation in Africa but I will just say
that
um we didn't set this agenda in a vacuum
we didn't send it set it for the topics
that mattered the most to us we said it
in consultation with our African
Partners on the issues that matter most
to them and to our shared future and I
would say that we're never satisfied
with the progress we've made because
there's always more work to do more
security to help bring about
more mitigation of uh of climate of
carbon emissions more adaptation to the
ravages of climate change more lives to
be saved through Health initiatives but
we feel we do enter the summit
um with some significant momentum around
major Investments that we have already
made and will continue to make and with
this announcement that over the next
three years we will be devoting 55
billion dollars to help address these
top priorities in very specific tangible
ways in partnership with African nations
so I think by the end of this what you
will see is a genuine energy and a
spirit of cooperation that will reflect
the fact that the United States has
unique assets and capabilities to bring
to bear and we're going to do everything
to bring those to bear in this time
period follow-up though um one what I
asked you
did
the United States loose ground with the
continent particularly sub-Saharan
Africa in the past four years when
Africa was not a focus
look any time
an Administration chooses not to put as
much energy or emphasis into a place it
obviously has some ramifications but I
have to say that since the president
since President Biden has come into
office whether it's through the
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment or it's through the work
we've done on covid-19 or it's through
the significant announcements that we've
made at both of the last two conferences
of parties on climate change we believe
that we are not coming into this Summit
from a standing start we're coming into
this Summit with a head of steam around
a set of issues that this Summit I think
is going to kick into a higher gear and
that is going to put us in a position
not just for us to succeed over the
course of next year the following year
but really over the course of this
decisive decade and I think you will see
a certain buoyancy a certain momentum a
certain enthusiasm emanating from the
course of the summit because
this isn't all just emerging out of thin
air it's emerging out of a very hard
very very much hard work over the course
of the past two years yeah Jake got a
couple questions about um your deputies
engagements in Asia right now
um first of all just with the China
meetings that are taking place
um with the vice foreign minister
um was there was there any discussion
about any support that the U.S could
provide to China as they unravel the
zero covet policy around vaccines around
support for
um for their medical system generally
so the topic of covid-19 and the ways in
which all countries including China are
dealing with this pandemic was on the
agenda at these meetings but I am going
to uh refrain from getting into details
of what those discussions entailed uh
because I want to give an opportunity
for us to be able to have those
conversations
um in sensitive diplomatic channels and
we'll see what if anything comes out of
them okay and then one more on that trip
I understand that Laura Rosenberg is
also meeting with the Japanese
delegation
um was there any discussion about an
agreement between the U.S Japan and then
everyone's about restricting this chip
making equipment from going to to China
I'm going to be your favorite person
ever at the podium because I'm going to
give a very similar answer which is that
of course we have consultations with all
of our allies and partners especially
those with a deep interest in the issue
of semiconductor Technologies about the
logic behind our own tailored
restrictions and about what the
landscape looks like we've had the those
conversations with both Japan and the
Netherlands and with other countries as
well and I'm not going to get ahead of
any announcements I will just say that
we are very pleased with the Candor the
substance and the intensity of the
discussions that are taking place across
a broad range of countries who share our
concerns and would like to see broad
alignment as we go do you have an
agreement in principle with those
countries again uh I'm not going to get
ahead of anything I'm just going to say
that
um it is of course the case
uh that a Hallmark of the Biden
Administration has been alignment with
allies and partners on every key foreign
policy issue we confront this is a
priority for us alignment is a priority
for us we're working towards that and
I'll leave any announcements to when
they're ripe to be made publicly from
this Podium or elsewhere yeah thanks
Jake there's a meeting today about the
next steps in trying to bring Paul
Whelan home are you part of that meeting
what can you tell us about that meeting
and the state department said today that
the U.S is going to be creative in
finding ways to get Paul Whelan released
what does that mean
so uh members of my team and the state
department met with Elizabeth Whelan
this morning virtually over Zoom I
wasn't a part of it today although I did
participate in the conversation the
president had with Elizabeth a few days
ago where they too were brainstorming
and talking through ideas
um about how to go forward
um
you'll understand that I can't get into
the specifics of the kinds of things
that we are contemplating to try to
ensure that we get Paul home as soon as
we can I will just say that the
conversations with Paul Whelan's family
have been substantive they have had a
number of
very good questions and also a number of
suggestions that they've put forward and
we have been working to figure out what
it is going to take to ultimately secure
his freedom and how we can go about
getting that and being able to sit down
with the Russians and work out a deal
um
the specifics of that are something that
really have to be kept in the sensitive
channels the sensitive conversations we
have with the wheel and family and then
the sensitive channels that we have with
the Russian government but we are bound
and determined to ensure uh that we work
through a successful method of securing
Paul Whelan's release at the earliest
possible opportunity plus doesn't have a
prisoner in custody that Russia would be
willing to make a trade for what else
could you do is there a policy that the
U.S would be willing to change in order
to get Russia to accept some kind of a
deal
I I can't really answer a question as
general as that I mean if the
implication is are we going to take a
different approach to Ukraine or
something like that the answer is no
we're not going to take a different
approach to Ukraine
um we believe that there are uh plays
that we can continue to try to run
things that we have had in motion that
we are still working on
um that that could potentially lead to a
positive result here uh again because of
the sensitivity of these issues I don't
want to go into detail on them but we
are going to keep working at this the
Big Challenge we had over the course of
the past several months is that what
Russia was asking for
to secure Paul wheelins release was not
something that we had to be able to give
that is a problem we are trying to solve
we have various ways that we are working
through Solutions and we will be
endeavoring on a daily basis from the
president on down to finally develop a
formula that works and that's as far as
I can go today but I will just reinforce
that our commitment to this is
absolutely Rock Solid intense and this
is as high a priority as the president
has yeah to follow on that because the
Administration has said that this deal
to get Greiner home was one or none so
if you're saying that what the Russians
were asking for for Whelan to come home
uh that was there ever a push by the
United States for that one to be Whelan
not Reiner in exchange for Victor Booth
as the president said uh when he
announced Brittany greiner's release for
totally illegitimate reasons
the Russians treat Paul Whelan's case
differently and so their demands related
to Paul Whelan are different from their
demands from other Americans to include
for example Trevor Reed who we were able
to secure his release earlier this year
even as Brittany Greiner remained in
custody in Russia and similarly they
treat his case differently from Brittany
greiner's case that creates a different
challenge for us in terms of what it
will take to get uh Paul Whelan home but
it is a challenge that we believe we are
up to we are going to figure out a way
to do it and that is just going to
require us to come up with the right
formula as I said before to be able to
present to the Russian Federation to
secure his release we're determined to
figure out how to do that that is what
we were working on that was the subject
and substance of the conversation with
Paul Whelan's family today and that will
be the work ahead and if I can do a
follow-up on grinder can you give us an
update on her condition when do you
expect that she might be departing for
Sam Houston in Texas and has the
president spoken with her or her family
since she's gotten back so I would defer
to the State Department officials who
are working closely with her at Fort Sam
Houston for an update on her condition
or directly to her or her family I don't
want to speak to that the reports we
have indicate that she is in good
spirits and and that she is in good
condition but again I cannot speak
authoritatively to it nor can I speak
authoritatively to when she will depart
because ultimately it's up to her how
she wants to go through this transition
from having been in confinement and in a
harrowing circumstance over the course
of the past several months back into her
her life here in the United States so
that would be up to her the president
has not had a chance to speak with
Brittany again since he spoke with her
shortly after her release but he's of
course following her case very closely
and continuing to pray for her for
shirelle and for the attire Griner
family that that she have this
opportunity and this space to heal as
she comes back from this awful situation
that she found herself in in Russia yeah
thanks Jake um I'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit more about the
possible deliverables out of the summit
um one thing that's been floated is
presidential travel to the continent and
whether that's a possibility I know that
you mentioned
um
specifically food shortages and the
problems that have sort of emanated out
of the war in Ukraine if there's
anything specific you can preview on
that and then
um if not I know some of it is building
up suspense for the actual announcement
but
um to conveco April's question I think
that there is concern that's been voiced
by African delegates and leaders that
the US kind of swoops in once every four
or eight years does one of these Summits
and then exits the stage and so if you
could talk a little bit about how you're
trying to reverse those perceptions and
specifically the perception that it's
kind of a great power battle between us
and China and and one that we're less
submitted to than maybe the Chinese so
I've given kind of the very headline
number which is is 55 billion over the
next three years
um over the course of the next three
days the president himself the vice
president and various cabinet members
will lay out deliverables and we will
shower you with detail about those
deliverables that involve you know real
mobilization of resources towards
concrete objectives so I'm not going to
get ahead of that today on on travel to
the continent I will say the president
the vice president members of the
cabinet there will be an announcement
about a broad-based commitment to travel
to the continent in 2023 but the precise
specifics of that I will also leave and
then we are very mindful of this
argument that says okay you hold the
summit and then everybody goes home and
doesn't it just go back to business as
usual that's why in my opening remarks I
made a point of stressing that we are in
fact going to a point uh a special
representative for Summit implementation
that will be his full-time
responsibility just to implement what
comes out of the summit and this is not
just somebody off the street this is
Johnny Carson who is an absolute Legend
of diplomacy uh coming out of the United
States on Africa and he brings as I said
before nearly four Decades of experience
and relationships across the continent
so we think there is not a better signal
or a better person in terms of the fact
that we are going to have a real genuine
follow-up than the fact that Johnny
Carson is going to be riding hurt over
that day in day out and if he puts his
mind to something he will get it done
and he will do so with the full
authority of the president and the
Secretary of State quick follow-on
Trevor's questions has there been any
progress on secretary blanken's travel
division
uh nothing to announce today although as
the two presidents indicated coming out
of the summit in Bali we have an
expectation that that will be coming in
the relatively near-term future yeah one
question on the summit and one on
another topic on the summit um I wanted
to ask about the inside list earlier
this year for the summit of the Americas
the administration did not invite
countries such as Cuba Venezuela
Nicaragua because of concerns about
human rights and democracy but on the
invite list this year or this week for
the African Summit you have countries
like Ethiopia Zimbabwe an Equatorial
Guinea where the Administration has also
expressed concerns about human rights or
democracy issues in those countries so
can you walk us through sort of the
discrepancies there and does the
administration have a lower bar for
human rights in Africa than countries
closer to here we have a common bar for
human rights the world over the way that
we went through the invites for the
African leader Summit was to do so in
close consultation with the African
Union and uh there are four countries
that are currently suspended for
membership in the African Union they
were not invited there was one country
with whom we don't have a normal
diplomatic relations Eritrea they were
not invited and everyone else was
invited and we will of course speak to
the universal values of Human Rights
democracy good governance
anti-corruption over the course of this
Summit but that's how we ended up with
the invite list for the African leader
Summit it was because of the
institutional engagement we had with the
African Union in designing not just who
would be invited to the summit but what
the substance of the agenda would be for
the summit so for example the
president's uh first session on Thursday
will be on agenda 2063. the African
Union's vision for the continent not on
something the United States is putting
forward as its as its own Vision but
um nonetheless you will see a commitment
over the course of three days to Civil
Society to lifting up Civil Society to
lifting up the voices of those who are
seeking human rights good governance
democracy and so forth and then of
course he will have a session on
elections in 2023 to speak to the
importance of of free and fair elections
in Africa as part of this and can you
also detail give any detail about that
about how the block release suspect was
taken into U.S custody well first I
would just say it is it is a very good
thing today is a good day because Masood
will be facing facing Justice for his
alleged role in the 1988 Lockerbie
bombing I will say that this was done in
a lawful manner according to established
procedures and for more specifics on how
it happened I would refer you to the
justice department because they're best
position to be able to speak to them
yeah okay your term question and longer
term question related to the
administration's abilities secure
agreement graduates which are at home
near term have there been any
discussions related to Paul Wheeler with
the Russians through the channels you
guys have been operating through in the
last five days if not is there a
timeline for that and then more broadly
it was a very clear mismatch between
what pretty brown I was alleged to have
done and what Victor Booth did do or it
was proven to do is the administration
trying to address that through other
channels ramp up pressure uh to Russia
against Russia because of that mismatch
or are these separate tracks entirely
well from our perspective if you look at
the full spectrum of pressure that we've
imposed upon the Russian Federation over
the course of the last year from
Financial sanctions to export controls
to our very strong and sustained support
for the ukrainians in defense of their
own Homeland we think that our record on
pushing back on the Kremlin in all
respects in particular million so far as
Russia represents a threat to Ukraine
and to our allies and partners is is
unmatched in recent memory so we take a
back seat to no one when it comes to
standing up against and pushing back
against Russian aggression we'll
continue to do so but we'll continue to
do so with a single question is it going
to make people in the United States
safer more secure and is it going to
advance our interests and values and if
there's any move we can make that will
do those things we will do them we have
proven that over the course of 2022.
with respect to the question of whether
we've had engagement with the Russian
Federation on the Wheeling case we will
have an engagement with them this week I
won't say more about it because we are
trying to keep that insensitive channels
but that's the timetable and we have had
regular engagement of course along the
way and the next conversation at a high
level will take place this week real
quick Victor booth has said that he
wants to be involved with the Russian
federation's efforts against Ukraine
with the administration plan to respond
should he do something like that whether
either tied to weapons or his political
activities
from our perspective what we want to do
is make sure that we are blunting any
Russian effort to be able to gain
advantage in Ukraine whether it's
military advantage or advantage through
brutalizing and destroying civilian
infrastructure so our focus is going to
be upon those things that actually
represent a genuine threat to Ukraine
and the people of Ukraine not to
comments that are made on television
shows and will continue to focus on that
as we go forward and for example just
last Friday we announced another 275
million dollars in Military Support to
Ukraine we will have further
announcements in the coming days so
we're going to look at what's actually
happening in the air and on the ground
in Ukraine not so much as what's
happening on the other air
on television stations in Russia
yes
thank you
in Africa we have the perception that
the U.S looked down Africa so with this
Summit uh what make you feel so
comfortable or confident that it will be
different so comparing to the preview or
Summit which didn't bring much result
for African countries what are you
seeing in this new Summit that you can
transmit to the African people that are
watching every Africans now are looking
on this Summit and expecting that the
U.S really at this time look in Africa
in a different way what make you
confident that this time will be
different I would say three things uh
make me confident that we will have a
positive result from the summit the
first is we are bringing the resources
to the table in significant numbers and
if you compare what the United States is
committing over the next three years to
to what any other country is committing
I think we stack up extremely favorably
second how did we design the agenda for
this Summit is not a dictation from
Washington it's not lecturing or
preaching from Washington we went to
African nations themselves in the
African Union and said what are your
priorities what is your vision and in
fact
the as I mentioned earlier
the entire first substantive session
that the president will chair at the
Summit is on agenda 2063 that is not an
American document it is not an American
Vision it is the African Union's
document in the African Union's Vision
so we are lifting up African voices and
African priorities and what we are doing
at this Summit and the entire Summit is
designed around that basic ethos and if
you look at the dinner the president's
going to host it is going to be him with
the leaders of Africa and their spouses
that small group in a room together for
hours being able to engage on the issues
of the day and then the third reason is
what we talked about earlier here which
is that we have put an emphasis on
implementation coming out of this Summit
like nobody has seen from previous
Summits meaning we will actually put
someone forward who is well known to
Africans respected somebody who has a
history of delivering on the major
issues that are of interest to African
people everywhere that's Johnny Carson
and so so we have not just a plan for
the next three days but for the years
that follow at the end of the day though
I agree with you it's not about what we
say it's about what we do and part of
the reason that I have so much
confidence about this Summit and what
will follow is because I do have
confidence that this President this vice
president this Secretary of State we are
intending to follow through we're
mobilizing the resources the people and
the process to be able to make that
happen and I think you will see in the
months that follow
uh the the results of all of this
actually reflected in reality
angolan investment recently our
President Biden announced two billion
dollar investment for Angola will there
be will there be any more investment
coming from Angola or what the president
really expect from this investment that
he announced many times for Angola so he
really expects that you will see a major
deployment of solar power in Angola that
was a significant uh project that was
facilitated by funding and mechanisms
from the United States government so
he's looking forward to seeing that
actually come to fruition at the summit
he will have a series of other
announcements that benefit a wide range
of countries in Africa some of which
also will come to the benefit of Angola
I will leave those to the specific
sessions in which each of these
announcements will be laid out but you
will see projects in health in climate
in trade and investment in
infrastructure and in many other areas
including security cooperation that
range from you know every signif
significant region of Africa benefiting
from different parts of what the
president and his team will lay out over
the next few days
Jake will finally the U.S
about the more than 19 million dollars
that the Equatorial Guinea pay to the
U.S government for vaccines but those
vaccines were never sent to Equatorial
Guinea well this time the U.S government
say something about this money that is
already in the U.S government but they
never sent the vaccines to you
Equatorial Guinea and the people still
waiting for those that sins we will have
the opportunity to speak with the
delegation from Equatorial Guinea about
any misunderstandings or misconceptions
that may lie at the heart of your
question yes thank you so much Jake uh
thanks for talking about Africa with us
first of all as you know a lot of
African countries have held the line
against condemning Russia um has the U.S
communicated any possible consequences
of maintaining that stance does any of
that 55 billion dollars play into that
what are the consequences if they
continue to to not choose a side in this
look we're not we're not putting a gun
to anyone's head we believe that the war
in Ukraine is a matter of principle and
it's not an American principle it's a
principle we all signed up to in the
United Nations Charter it's principle of
sovereignty and territorial Integrity so
we will make the case with passion and
persistence to every country in the
world that they should speak out against
these flagrant violations of the U.N
Charter but we're not imposing
conditionality from the point of view of
this Summit on decisions that Sovereign
countries make in this regard we believe
that we have actually been successful in
pressing this case in fact from the
first significant general assembly vote
of 141 countries condemning The Invasion
to the second significant general
assembly vote where you actually had an
increase 143 countries even after
several months in which people were
describing uh you know flagging
International support for Ukraine the
numbers went up and we think that that
is because countries recognize there are
deeper principles at stake that's how
we're approaching this we're not
approaching this from the point of view
of coercing other countries that's not
how the United States is going to
operate with respect to countries in
Africa it's not how we have operated yes
elections Jake uh you mentioned the 2023
elections in Africa can you just
highlight the ones that you're concerned
about how the U.S is going to work with
these countries I'm thinking of Congo
Sudan and South Sudan that are having
big ones next year so what are you going
to do to make space for them to have
these elections I want to be clear that
um having a meeting about elections in
2023 is not about us
raising the alarm Bell or claiming you
know we've got concerns and then
Solutions it's rather to say there are
important elections coming up
we would like to do everything we can to
support those elections being free fair
and credible and that goes for every
election taking place in 2023 not
picking and choosing certain ones and
setting other ones aside so the meeting
is designed uh to to indicate that the
United States is focused on being
supportive of free fair and credible
elections everywhere they are taking
place in Africa in 2023. sorry I've got
it I'm sorry I've got it thank you Jake
another protester was executed in Iran
this time in a Public Square it was
hanged and his trial was described as a
sham his accusation was he waging a war
against God what can the U.S do to
support these protesters who bravely
participated in in this demonstrations
but they're being held or arrested and
second can you update us on any
potential meeting between you or the
president with the families of the
American Iranian hostages held in Tehran
and they've been asking for a meeting
with you
so I have had a chance to meet with the
namazi family I have had a chance to
meet with Murad tabaz's family and in
just the next few days I will also have
a chance to meet with Ahmad charges
family so I've already in the past
through zoom in person on the phone
engaged deeply with
many people who have been personally
affected by their family members being
detained unjustly unlawfully detained in
Iran and this is something that I
personally as nationally security
advisor and deeply committed to across
the board I've spent dozens if not
hundreds of hours working on these cases
meeting with these families and I will
continue to do so as we go forward and I
make it a policy that any family that
seeks a meeting at the White House with
me will get one sometimes there are
scheduling issues but over the course of
the past year I have had the opportunity
to meet with so many families from
hostages and and detainees in Russia and
Afghanistan and Venezuela Iran and China
and other places as well and I'll
continue to do that on the um on the
question of what we're doing with
respect to supporting the protesters in
Iran we have had a drumbeat of
announcements relative to sanctions
against those who are perpetrating these
gross human rights abuses and this
repression we haven't just done so
ourselves we have coordinated and
aligned with other countries around the
world building an international chorus
of condemnation against what is
happening in addition we have taken
steps to try to facilitate the ability
of Iranians to communicate both among
themselves and then to communicate to
the outside world what is happening in
their country so that we can shine a
bright light on and hold accountable
those who are responsible we will
continue to do these things and right
from the president who has spoken very
directly clearly and passionately on the
subject on down this government has made
clear where it stands it's stands on the
side of the rights of peaceful
protesters the rights of women to to
seek to vindicate their human dignity
and the rights of people everywhere to
speak out on behalf of a better life and
we will continue to do that yeah pull
your punches on China and you won't say
the same thing for the protests there
will you well we have spoken about the
protests in China and called for
peaceful protests we have spoken about
xinjiang we've spoken about what's
happened in Hong Kong and in fact what's
just happened with respect to Jimmy Lai
is a in our view a violation of the
basic law and the commitments that China
made with respect to autonomy for Hong
Kong so this Administration does have a
very strong uh set of principles and
actions that we've taken over the course
of the past two years with respect to
the People's Republic of China and the
question of Human Rights yeah I wanted
to ask you about the African leader
Summit but first just a quick follow-up
I'm curious does the administration
consider Victor Vu to be a 10 terrorist
well he's not listed as a specially
designated national what we consider him
to have been was a convicted criminal
convicted of arms trafficking and other
crimes to serve a sentence he served 12
years in detention he was set to be
released in 2029 and of course before we
make any determination about whether to
send somebody back as part of a deal to
get an American home we make a
determination about the National
Security implications of that we did
that assessment in this case we believe
we can manage those challenges but we
will remain constantly Vigilant against
any threat that Victor boot May pose to
Americans to the United States going
forward we also would just point out uh
that there is no shortage of arms
traffickers and mercenaries in Russia
who pose challenges and threats to the
international order to the United States
and otherwise and we are Vigilant about
that as well which is why we have built
alongside our allies and partners such a
robust policy and dealing with the
threats posed by question about the
African leader Summit as China looks to
increase its influence on that continent
I'm curious will the president seek to
deliver any kind of message or word of
warning uh to these African leaders that
Beijing whether it's through their
financing or economic or military aid
is not in fact
a faithful Ally or partner
this is going to be about what we can
offer it's going to be a positive
proposition about the United States
partnership with Africa it's not going
to be about other countries it's not
going to be attempting to compare
contrast it's rather going to be about
the affirmative agenda that the United
States has to bring to bear with Africa
yeah thank you thank you
I went around yesterday to see how much
African Leaders with painful deal done
for this trip and I realized that some
of the hotels in DC were charging them
up to 22 000 a night so it's an
expensive trip some of them we spend 50
million dollars for countries where
people live on less than a US dollar ID
and so my question is if they have to
spend all this money and travel
thousands of miles why wasn't the White
House wetting the White House plan
one-on-one meeting with those African
leaders well first the president will
have the chance to greet every single
African leader and engage with them as
they come for the dinner tomorrow night
second if you look at the substance of
this Summit the sessions that he is
going to sit with those leaders around
the table and deal with it is the things
that they have asked to talk about that
he will be talking about with them and
those leaders will have the opportunity
to speak in those sessions to President
Biden and to one another so that we can
collectively come up with a common
strategy to deliver for the people of
Africa and if you look at what substance
this Summit is going to deliver from the
business Forum all the way through to
the leader sessions I believe that it is
going to be three days where you will
see put on display real tangible
deliverables and results that are going
to improve people's lives and ultimately
as I said before I will ask you judge us
on the record of how that ends up
playing out but I'm confident that it is
going to play out well
my final question
42 is
do you see a national security uh are
there National conservative concerns
over the title 42 expiration so the team
has been working very hard to ensure
that we are taking steps to be able to
manage the expiration of title 42 and to
put in place a process that will be
orderly and Humane and we believe that
in doing so we can protect our national
security concerns that is a process that
others can speak to better than I can
but from my perspective the issues
related to ensuring an orderly Humane
migration process at the border are
being persistently and constantly
addressed through the interagency
process and we are working through what
the procedures will be in place at the
moment of expiration on the 21st
of how many people are coming across
that they have that there is no
visibility on how many people are
crossing that you have no idea who they
are
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand the
question how many people crossing the
border that the US government has no
idea
of how many people crossing aren't
giving their name aren't giving IDs
aren't able to verify who they are so we
do have estimates of how many encounters
there are at the border on a daily basis
we have processes and procedures in
place to identify those individuals to
process them in an orderly fashion and
then to do what is appropriate based on
that processing and we have believed
that that system uh is a system that
does an effective job of being able to
determine who is coming across the
border and what the right way to deal
with their case is yes
on the IRA issue
but a lot of times after CSI is
confidence you mentioned that you will
have some kind of a solution for the IIA
but you haven't heard regarding the
issue of subsidy exclusive products
South Korean electric vehicles
under the IIA what kind of talks are
going on with South Korea now and what
solution does the United States have for
Mutual benefit as an economic alliance
with South Korea so we have had
extensive consultations with the
Republic of Korea on the inflation
reduction act and in particular the uh
the relevant Provisions related to
electric vehicles those have been
constructive conversations they've
happened at multiple levels including a
discussion between our two presidents
and we feel confident that we can get to
a place of understanding and where both
of our country's economic interests will
be taken into account and we will see
that unfold in the in the coming days
and weeks this is a big complex piece of
legislation not everything gets resolved
in a day a week or a month but we
believe that we will ultimately have a
long-term approach that vindicates the
uh economic interest the needs of
American workers and businesses and of
our Ally in the Republic of Korea I'll
leave it at that thanks guys
thank you Jay
all right I know we're
kind of running out of time so I'll take
a I'll do two things at the top and take
a few more questions for folks
many of you have been asking about plans
for tomorrow's Bill signing tomorrow
President Biden will sign the bipartisan
respect for Marriage Act into law at a
celebration on the south lawn with
thousands in attendance in May 2012 then
Vice President Biden made history when
he said and I quote
is all about a simple proposition
who do you love who do you love and who
you who who you'll be loyal to in person
to the person you love will you be loyal
to to the person you love end quote the
respect for Marriage Act helps ensure
that proposition is fully realized in
the United States it will give peace of
mind to millions of lgbtqi plus and
interracial couples who will finally be
guaranteed the rights and protections to
which they and their children are
entitled to
the legislation also enjoys support from
a majority of Americans across party
lines and Fates tomorrow the president
will be joined by a bipartisan group of
lawmakers as well as advocates and
plaintiffs in marriage equality cases
across the country to sign this critical
legislation into law
there will be musical guests and
performances to celebrate this historic
bill and the president will also note
that there is much more work to be done
to protect the lgbtqi plus individuals
across the country to protect and
including
passing the equality act as well
and before we go into questions I have
one more thing that I I want to address
from here is um is about what the
president you've heard what the
president has been focusing on which is
rallying the world diplomatically you
heard that from uh from uh National
Security adviser Jake Sullivan and
continue to re-establish Americans
leaders American leadership abroad
protecting people's constitutional
rights by codifying marriage equalities
I just discussed
but what is in the incoming house uh
Republican majority doing uh one of
their leaders majority Taylor Greene
Marjorie Taylor green is saying quote if
Steve Bannon and I organized January 6
we would have won not to mention it
would have been armed this is what is
coming from a member of Congress
and what's more she said to a group that
lashed out against condemning Holocaust
denial they were giving her an award
you have all heard the president warn
about awful conspiracy theories and
violent rhetoric that he used to be
undermined uh which which undermined the
rule of law in our democracy it is just
antithetical to our values as a country
for a member of Congress to wish that
the Carnage of January 6 had been even
worse and to brag that they would have
succeeded in an armed Insurrection
against the United States government
violent rhetoric like this is also a
slap in the face of the Capitol Police
the D.C metropolitan police the National
Guard and the families who lost loved
ones as a result of the attack on the
capitol
and this is someone who is expected to
have their committee positions restored
so we should let that sink in again this
is coming from a member of Congress
all leaders have a responsibility to
condemn these dangerous vile remarks and
stand for our Constitution and also for
the rule of law
with that sung Me
for the musical guests
I'm not gonna share I don't want to take
away from the excitement but it's going
to be a celebrated a celebrated event as
the president signs this historic piece
of legislation into law and as I stated
there'll be thousands of people there
and of course we'll have musical guests
and it'll be a bipartisan also
um a bipartisan event and attended by
lawmakers who helped to make this happen
and this is a reminder if I may add how
when when we do reach across the aisle
there are things that we can get done
historic pieces of legislation that we
can get done and we have seen that under
this President so I think that's
important to note as well yeah sure
um I just wanted to get the White
House's perspective on the current
government funding talks uh Schumer
talked about doing a one
ER Democrats we're going to release
their own legislation but held off does
the White House see these as encouraging
signs for being able to get abroad
Omnibus by the end of the month so look
we continue to encourage Congress to get
the to get a bipartisan deal done we
believe on the government funding we
believe there is still enough time to
get that done this is something that
clearly Congress was able to do this
time last year in a bipartisan way but
if they need extra days to get there uh
so be it we got to remember this is not
a partisan issue the issues that we are
talking about we talk about National
Security we just had Jake Sullivan here
as I just noted a second ago we talked
about public education we're talking
about health care these are and Veteran
veterans veteran Health Services to be
more even more specific these are
priorities for the American people these
are bipartisan issues that are critical
critical uh to American individuals just
across the country so again we encourage
Congress to reach a bipartisan deal
um I had another Africa Summit question
um Reuters has reported in recent days
that the Nigerian Army um has been
running a secret systematic and illegal
abortion program in the country since
2013. do you expect that to be a topic
of discussion of the Nigerian delegation
again Jake it's Jake laid out how each
individual
African leader will have an opportunity
to talk and discuss and have
conversations with the president who he
very much looks forward to doing that
I'm not going to get ahead on what may
come up we may not come up we've laid
out pretty extensively at least the top
lines as you've just heard from Jake
what we believe our goals are we talked
about the 55 billion dollars that we in
new funding that we'll be providing to
the continent in next three three years
which we believe is incredibly important
we talked about uh Johnny Carson who is
going to be the the leader in making
sure that uh what what comes out the
deliverables that come out of this
Summit uh is actually delivered it if
you will and so look we are committed to
this not going to get ahead of of that
particular conversation but certainly
that's something that we're monitoring
trying to free Paul Whelan
um is this Administration uh drawing a
line in trading any type of sanctions
relief to secure Paul Whelan's release
when it comes to Ukraine yeah look when
it comes to Ukraine and Jake said this
when it comes to Ukraine we are pretty
uh we've been you know pretty emphatic
about this pretty steadfast that we are
going to uh as a matter of of uh you
know the right thing to do as a matter
of protecting a country's democracy and
lifting up and making sure that the
people of Ukraine have what they need to
fight for their freedom fight for their
sovereignty this is something that we've
been doing clearly with our allies and
partners that won't change and Jake kind
of laid that out I think pretty clearly
when it really as it relates to what
we're discussing uh what is being
negotiated when it uh as uh you know as
it relates to Paul wheeling and getting
him home I'm not going to get into
negotiations from here I'm not going to
get into specifics as Jake laid out as
well look we are committed to getting
Americans who were being wrongfully
detained and held hostage abroad home
that is a promise that this president
has made we have seen that across the
almost two years of his presidency with
Brittany Greiner with Trevor uh Trevor
Reed just in April and so we're going to
continue that and and have those
conversations but in private certainly
not going to lay them out from here
to ask about the attack on the
substation in North Carolina and whether
the White House believes that the
federal government should regulate
substation substation security I'm sorry
I'm having a hard time hearing you sure
let me take my mask off I said um I
wanted to ask about the substation
attack in North Carolina and whether the
White House believes that the federal
government should regulate secure yet
substations instead of leaving it up to
States and the individual utility
company so look I'm not gonna I know the
department of energy is looking into
this the Department of Justice is
looking into this there is a um they're
reviewing this process I'm not going to
get ahead of that I would uh certainly
refer you to those two agencies but just
not going to get ahead as they're
reviewing that process okay what's the
president's thinking right now about uh
the National Defense authorization Act
and the vaccine requirement and clearly
his position on vaccines is well known
and there's a long history of signing
and passing the ndaa where's he at with
that so look we've been very clear about
what we saw happen with the vaccine
mandate uh basically being removed or
from the ndaa we thought it was a
mistake we think that republicans in
Congress have decided that they'd rather
fight against the health and well-being
of our troops than protecting them and
again it was a mistake as it relates to
the ndaa we're not going to get ahead
the Senate is is going to take this up
so we're not going to get ahead of the
Senate process but I've said this before
look when in the past every year when
when the NDA comes up there are some
Provisions we support some that we do
not the president will judge the bill in
its entirety so not going to get ahead
of what the president's action is going
to be but we've been very clear about
how we how we see the vaccine mandate
[Music]
Friday the administration issued a
fairly strong rebuke of a WTO decision
that essentially said the steel and
aluminum tariffs in place violated
International rules I just want to make
sure I understand where the
administration stands on steel and
aluminum tariffs
um and does it mean that essentially you
will intend for those tariffs to remain
in place indefinitely
so um I saw that reporting and so what
we what we say from here
um so we we um strongly reject uh the
flawed interpretation and conclusions in
the report in the World Trade
Organization panel reports that we saw
that you're uh laying out there the
United States has held the clear and
unequivocal position for over 70 years
that issues of National Security cannot
be reviewed in WTO a dispute settlement
the Biden Administration is committed to
preserving U.S national security by
ensuring the long-term viability of our
steel and aluminum Industries and we do
not intend to remove the section 230 232
duties as a result of these disputes
again we reject the false the the flawed
interpretation that's been laid out
relatedly I know there was a lot of talk
earlier this summer about the broad
sweeping scale of China tariffs and
there was some expectation that this
might be Revisited after the president's
visit of due any update or timeline on
what's going on I guess what the China
tariffs as they are no I appreciate the
question and I understand as it relates
to this don't have anything to preview
on on that particular topic
more than 70 members of Congress said
hello to the president on Friday asking
him to take executive action to
guarantee you the real world real
ordered paid Subway
is is it clear that that there are steps
that can be taken through executive
action or is the White House determined
that this is something that Congress uh
can only do so first I want to say uh
you know the president is grateful to
Congress for taking action to avert uh a
rail shutdown and implement the benefits
he helped secure for rail workers in the
tentative agreement so we are grateful
to Congress for doing that he's also
grateful to Senator uh Sanders and
representative Bowman's continued
advocacy for paid paid sick leave the
president has press Congress to advance
the cause of paid sick leave throughout
his administration we've had many
debates and discussions from from the
podium about that about his efforts in
in that realm uh he's exploring all
options here while working to build on
existing bipartisan support in Congress
to make paid sick leave a reality for
all workers all workers including rail
workers as well again we are going to
look at all options here potential it is
possible that executive executives
taking you have to roll that out then
don't have anything to announce or lay
out on how we're going to move forward
what I can say is we are going to look
at all options and we are very very
grateful uh to Congress for uh you know
for helping to avert this rail shutdown
which would as you all know would have
had and uh really Disturbed our economy
in a way that uh would have been uh not
not great not helpful clearly for
American families across the country uh
and uh and look this is an issue that
the president has been fighting for when
it comes to paid leave for all Americans
throughout the last two almost two years
of his administration and we're going to
continue to look at all options
has the president been briefed on the
news coming out of the Department of
energy tomorrow on the fusion
development at the Livermore Lane so um
just a couple of things on that as you
know the department of Energy's analysis
is is still ongoing so I I'm unable to
provide details of confirmation at this
time uh secretary grantolm will have
more details to share tomorrow when the
process is complete I'm not going to get
ahead of that at this time
conference
confidence
oh I'm so sorry end of your conference
I don't have anything to preview on that
or to announce on an end-of-year press
conference
um if when we do we and when if we will
certainly we'll share that with you okay
thank you for your question I'll take a
couple more uh go ahead Courtney
traveler vaccine
vaccine present going knew it are you
going to let it expire what's the next
step don't have anything to preview on
the next steps on on that particular
question once we do we certainly show
that
and I wanted to ask you
negotiations in Congress about the child
tax credit can you talk about where you
are on that and what some of the
sticking points have been
so as I said over a month ago I believe
from from the podium our position is
simple if Congress is going to extend
tax cuts and tax breaks for business in
the lame duck they must include tax
relief for Working Families that's the
way we see this process moving forward
some sort of tax credit for children is
the most direct way to do that and as as
I have noted before there are several
proposals from both Democrats and also
Republicans to provide such relief it is
not clear to us if Congress has an
interest in pushing a tax bill in the
remaining two weeks our point is simple
no tax breaks for business businesses
without tax relief for working families
and children and that's where we're
going to continue to be on this
follow up with one more do you feel that
um I know that some of the conversation
has been around limits for the child tax
credit on who qualifies based on income
do you feel that the IRS or treasury
would be prepared to administer such a
tax credit given all the different
demands that they have and now adding on
more restrictions as opposed to it was
much more broad earlier so I'm not going
to get ahead of what of what the process
might look like what I can say you know
definitively of how we see this process
moving forward at least in Congress and
again we are uh you know we're not clear
if this is going to happen but we've
pretty much laid out our our Pro our our
belief or how we see this moving which
is no tax breaks for businesses without
tax relief for working families and and
children just not going to get ahead of
what can potentially how this process is
going to work through the federal
government if if and when this were to
happen go ahead Alex in the back thank
you great
um as you know um Elon Musk who launched
a series of attacks on documentary about
you over the weekend calling for his
prosecution and then he shared some
other memes about him and suggested he
lied about he's lying about the origins
of the coronavirus what's what's your
response uh first of all to specifically
to the attacks on uh Dr fauci and second
uh how is your view of Twitter
as a sort of public forum and a form for
yourself and for the president and many
other officials here how how are those
views evolving so like we've been very
clear about this these attacks these
personal attacks that we have been
seeing are dangerous uh on Dr fauci and
other public health professionals as
well are they are disgusting and they
are divorced from uh from reality and we
will continue to call that out and be
very clear about that again these are
incredibly dangerous these personal
attacks that we are seeing Dr fauci has
served under seven Republican and
Democratic presidents we cannot forget
that he has given he has given his
almost entire career to silver Civil
Service uh public sir as a public
servant his work on infectious disease
from HIV AIDS the covid has saved
countless lives and uh you know it's
unfortunate that he has uh you know we
we are fortunate I should say that he
has devoted his career uh and his life
uh and his exceptional talent to the
America's Public Health to America's
public health and that's what should be
discussed right now that's what we
should be thankful to him about and
again these are incredibly dangerous and
should be called out I'll leave it there
appreciate it we know the respect for
mayor Jack is going to be signed
tomorrow on the south lawn but you know
and the president himself he told me the
other day that he disagrees with
Catholic Bishops the Bishops of course
believe that it will harm religious
freedom
that said the Scooby side it was a done
deal but what did the president say to
religious organizations who fear they
will now be targeted or discriminated
against by the government for their
beliefs in traditional marriage
so look
um you know on his first day in in the
White House the president signed um and
is an executive order uh on preventing
the combating Discrimination
discrimination against lgbtqi plus
Americans uh and that EO has led key
agencies including HUD HHS Ed doj and
cfpb to strengthen non-discrimination
Protections in housing Health Care
education criminal systems and credit
and lending services and so I say that
because he has been so committed to this
issue from the beginning of his
administration and when you uh when you
look at this piece of legislation that
has been passed it actually addresses
also the question that you're asking and
takes that into account but look this is
going to be tomorrow's going to be a
really important day for many Americans
millions of Americans across the country
and I think we cannot forget that
I'm going to move on I'm going to move
on I'm going to move around okay thank
you I have a question on African leader
Summit
um my colleague already asked this
question but I want to ask you about it
is no secret that China has bigger
influence and more investment more trade
with Africa and I understand this Summit
is not about specific countries but it's
about sending a primitive message but I
want to ask you what kind of role do you
expect for this Summit to play in terms
of competing the influence over Africa
against China look I want to be very
careful here I'm not going to go beyond
what the Pres what the what Jake just
stated it's not going to be about China
it's going to be about Africa it we
worked very closely with African nations
as Jake said and also the African Union
about what is important that they want
to talk about and discuss with the
president not just the president the
vice president or cabinet secretaries
and so that's going to be the focus
that's why we announced the 55 billion
dollars that's why we announce uh
someone who is going to make sure that
over the next uh over the next couple of
years as we continue to move forward
with our relationship with Africa the
things that we discussed our
deliverables will occur will happen and
showing our commitment and so I think
that's where we want to stay that's what
we want to focus us on on how we can
move that relationship forward and what
we can do to assist the continent all
right thanks everybody see you tomorrow